he is braved some of the most perilous
situations in the world but now his most
intimidating assignment dancing the
Cha-cha-cha on National Television it's
political journalist Tucker Carlson and
his professional partner Elena granenko
my name is Dr Carlson I'm a journalist I
wrote for magazines and newspapers for
about 10 years and I've been in
television news for about six there are
some unknown number of Israeli forces
the hundreds maybe the thousands when I
first got the call about doing this I
thought they must be calling the wrong
guy My Dance Experience consists of
drinking too much at a couple rehearsal
dinners it's
performance baby
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report it
is April 25th 2023 we are live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals if you have
not joined us yet at
reubenreport.locals.com what do I have
to do
what do I have to do to make it happen
please do join us post game show after
every show you can ask me questions
comments we do some now that it cannot
be overstated this Tucker Carlson
leaving Fox
whether it was somewhat voluntarily or
whether they pushed him out the door or
whether it was a little bit of both and
perhaps we'll find out all the answers
to that it's actually irrelevant it is
causing a chain reaction throughout the
system not only through the media system
right cable news streaming video all of
that but throughout the political
machine as well because Tucker
is a voice for an awful lot of people
who do not otherwise have a voice
especially in a mainstream sense this
thing is heating up I have some sense of
of where it could end up but we shall
see on that front and we are going to
unpack it today we are going to unpack
it by talking about what sort of put
Tucker on the map you know and it has a
little something to do with being brave
it has a little something to do with
telling the truth it has a little
something to do with being outside of
the system and trying to as he would
often talk about you know you can't
necessarily blow up the whole system but
you can you can move it on the margins
and I think if you do that and you fight
for what you believe in and you're
authentic and then you get more people
to replicate that across the way I think
that's actually how things get better if
more people acted on their
good Angels uh and I think there's a
chance you know the Elon Twitter stuff
Tucker leaving potentially going
independent you guys get it like all the
pieces are here and what do I often say
it's like man we've been all trying to
piece together a puzzle the puzzle
pieces are all in front of us we don't
have the box so we don't know exactly
what we're trying to put together but
it's starting to take shape uh and I
think what happened yesterday and what
now will transpire over the next couple
weeks related to this are going to be a
big marker in whatever that puzzle is
supposed to look like uh before we get
to any of that let me talk to you guys
about Mike box you guys know that 60 of
U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day guys
there's a better way I want to tell you
about moink that is Moo plus oink moink
delivers grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and sustainable wild caught Alaskan
salmon straight to your door you you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes and chicken breasts to
pork chops and salmon fillets and much
more plus you can cancel any time
there's nothing better than cooking my
Meats on a Friday night on my big green
egg Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got minked
keep American farming going by signing
up at mikebox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
a year of the best filet mignon you'll
ever taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-k box.com slash
reubenwinkbox.com Reuben and now back to
me okay so Fox Fox News The Big Boy in
cable news right they have just in the
last week week and a half let go not
only of Tucker Carlson
but also Dan bongino these are probably
their two biggest guys you could put
Gutfeld Gutfeld obviously number one in
cable news you can put him in there too
so let's say two of their three biggest
guys right now uh but the question is
and there was this Dominion lawsuit that
they lost and obviously there's been
some ideological wrangling at Fox are we
going to go all Trump is it going to be
more DeSantis like which way does this
thing go how much editorial control do
the hosts have in all of those things uh
it's all up in the air right now so
let's uh let's start with some of the
Tucker stuff so the daily wire broke it
yesterday breaking Tucker Carlson out at
Fox News Channel and in their piece I
wanted to read just a bit for you uh
Tucker Carlson Fox Fox News Channel's
biggest Prime Time star has left the
cable news giant Fox news media and
Tucker Carlson have agreed to part ways
Fox News said in a statement we thank
him for his service to the network as a
host and prior to that that as a
contributor the network said Carlson had
already hosted his last episode of
Tucker Carlson tonight Mr Carlson's last
program was Friday April 21st the
statement continued Carlson was almost
always at the top of the ratings in
Prime Time drawing a massive audience
that often dwarfed several of his
competitors combined as the daily wire
previously reported Carlson's show in
reruns often eclipsed the audience of
original programming at other networks A
source told the daily wire Carlson's
staff was blindsided by the news and
only learned late Monday morning when
members received an email from The
Primetime star the popular hosts abrupt
exit comes just under a week after the
network settled a lawsuit with Dominion
voting systems for just under 800
million dollars narrowly avoiding a
trial in which Carlson would have been
expected to testify the news of
Carlson's departure comes just a week
after syndicated radio host and former
secret service agent Dan bongino
announced that he was leaving Fox News
citing a breakdown in contract
negotiations folks regretfully last week
was my last show on Fox news on the Fox
News Channel bongino said on his podcast
at the time so the show ending last week
was tough and I want you to know it's
not some big conspiracy I promise you
there's not there's no acrimony this
wasn't some like WWE brawl that happened
we just couldn't come to terms on an
extension and that's really it he added
for his part Carlson has yet to publicly
address the exit and no reports have yet
begun to circulate regarding any
potential future plans okay so look for
any of you that know anything about
media things will leak out right like
over the next weeks and months we will
find out more and did this have
something to do with the Dominion
lawsuit did Tucker want to keep
exploring election fraud and they just
didn't want him to anymore did it have
anything to do with his January 36th
reporting like we will find out what
happened here but the fact that it
happened so abruptly and that it was
from a guy this wasn't like just getting
rid of like some random person in
daytime or even some you know remote you
know decently let's say rated Host this
is the number one guy in the history of
cable news he took over the slot from
Bill O'Reilly who had been number one
for like 15 years in a row and then he
increased on that nobody really thought
that was going to happen and then
obviously he was deeply connected to the
Trump thing and the Maga thing and and
the populist ideal and the anti-war
movement so he was doing something that
other Cable News hosts even on his own
network were not doing now what he did
not have at Fox is total and ultimate
control how do I know that well here he
is in my house in my garage when I lived
in Los Angeles this is 2018 so about
five years ago here is Tucker and I
talking about independence and what I
had at the time that he did not have at
the time
Tucker Carlson welcome to the Reuben hey
Dave I am glad to have you here my
friend I'm glad to be here I love this I
don't know that anyone has ever walked
in here and been more impressed by the
Ruger because I work in television so I
know what this is and it's just the
coolest thing I've seen in a long time
are you jealous are you joking yes I'm
jealous you have millions and millions
of viewers I have a massive staff
but I don't have the control that you
have which is wonderful yeah control
have which is wonderful so I think
Tucker has already tipped off to us what
he really wants he wants that ultimate
control now I have no idea if Fox and
Tucker Carlson or Tucker Carlson's
producers had gotten into any fights
over control but the simple fact is when
you work for somebody else when someone
else signs the paychecks and there's an
editorial staff at Fox News and
everything else there is some level of
control whether it's tacit or obvious or
subtle or whatever it might be he did
not own the property that's why he they
were able to end the contract with him
so five years ago Tucker's sitting in my
garage in Los Angeles going man you're
doing it the right way well subsequently
in these last five years obviously the
independent Creator movement has
absolutely exploded so I think I've just
put that there as a little just want you
to put a little pin in that one as we
explore what happens over the next
couple weeks and as Tucker makes some
announcements which I'm sure are coming
because I sense we know where Tucker
will go but we shall see I want to talk
to you about the media reaction to all
of that and also let's not forget guys
the other thing that happened yesterday
is that Don Lamont also known as Don
Lemon but Tucker's been calling him Don
Lemon for years he got canned at CNN
like an hour later what a whack
wacky wacky day in media yesterday was
so we're going to get to a whole bunch
of reaction on all this and how it
affects the political situation because
these things are deeply deeply
intertwined before we do that let me
talk about Phoenix Capital you know guys
with banks collapsing and turbulent the
turbulent state of the stock market
millions of Americans have watched their
retirement savings disappear I want to
share with you a unique investment
opportunity that is not only protecting
retirement savings but investors are
seeing consistent yields and growth
Phoenix Capital group is offering
high-value U.S oil and gas Investments
through their corporate bonds it's a way
for people to invest in energy assets
and diversify their portfolio yields
range from 8 to 12 percent apy paid
monthly with different qualifications
and maturity dates Phoenix Capital group
is a tech-led Energy company owning in
some of the most lucrative basins Across
America investor Capital along with
their own Capital goes towards cash flow
positive oil and gas projects they had
the choice of offering a significantly
lower interest rate and paying the
difference to middlemen but decided to
break the mold and bring stronger
Investments directly to investors these
eight to twelve percent apy corporate
bonds are higher than CDs or annuities
often more than double the typical
yields so if you're looking for an
alternative investment with sizable
yields and monthly payment options I
highly recommend checking out Phoenix
Capital groups Bond offerings to learn
more download their free investor guide
at PHX on reuben.com
phxon reuben.com and tell them Dave send
you all right let's talk about the media
reaction because shocker shocker a
certain amount of people are very very
excited that Tucker Carlson will not be
on Fox News tonight at 8 pm let's start
with the shrieking harpies at the view
because the news broke while they were
on air you know the view is on right now
some of you know this it's 11 A.M
Eastern that's when we do this show
every day that's the same time that the
view is on that means there are people
mostly Housewives eaten bon bons
watching The View right now so we broke
the news live on air because we heard
about it just as it was breaking the
view did as well our reactions were I
would say slightly different
word has just come down that Fox news
media and Tucker Carlson have agreed to
part ways
of Prior contributor wave
you know we'll talk more about it
tomorrow because but we wanted to make
sure that we let you know what was going
on well can I can I ask the audience if
they'll help me do something
come on folks
hey goodbye
I mean sayonara
[Applause]
Navarro you know on any given day you
can honestly argue that each one of them
is the worst host I know I've been more
of a sunny host and is like a psychopath
deranged lunatic racist but Anna like on
any given day you just never know poor
Joy wasn't even there for it yesterday
must have been getting her face
rearranged anywho uh the
short-sightedness of these women is
really extraordinary because they're
they're applauding that a guy that they
don't like who has a different Viewpoint
than them even though the show is called
The View and Barbara Walters originally
set it up so that you'd hear different
views different points of view from
different people which is the reverse of
what the show has become uh what they
seem to not realize is that Tucker is
now right at this moment bigger than
he's ever been he's bigger than he was
two days ago and he was pretty freaking
huge two days ago he's not going away
right he's not disappearing he's not
gonna not have a show or not be involved
in Media or politics he's probably going
to do something much bigger if you
strike me down Darth I will become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
watch Star Wars ladies do you not get it
don't you know how this thing works but
okay you can sing and applaud and get
your temporary little win but I assure
you ladies it will not last long uh
here's CNN uh covering Tucker leaving
it's Anderson Cooper and Democrat
strategist Paul bagalla and he's uh well
this is this is wonderful analysis I
can't imagine why nobody watches this
crap
do the remaining hosts at Fox whoever
replaced in soccer Carlson is there any
there's no incentive to tone down their
own rhetoric is there
no they're not going to change I think
right wing media in the last 25 years
has it been all about the Overton window
right what was unacceptable 20 years ago
Tucker didn't say any of those things
when I worked with him at Crossfire is
now mainstream conservative media and
it's only going to get more here's okay
you know what I'd like to see here's how
we'll know that fox has changed they
won't do it fox has changed if they
replace Tucker with an undocumented
Mexican immigrant that would actually
truly be a great replacement
um I can't imagine that Maria Bartiromo
is sleeping well tonight I mean
is that funny
it wasn't funny okay I just had to check
yeah it's not funny uh but putting aside
that it's not funny you know Fox News
even without Tucker is still going to
have better ratings than CNN and
Anderson Cooper and the rest of it right
they still have a bunch of hosts there
that people still love right a certain
set of people still love uh Hannity tons
and tons of people still love Greg
Gutfeld and what's going on over at the
five and all that
um would they tone down the rhetoric Fox
is the only look regard you may be angry
at Fox right now and I think there's
reasons to be angry at Fox for sure
um we will find out the specifics of
some of that and actually what happened
like I don't know for all you know if
Tucker if Tucker beat a woman or
something and that's why he's leaving
then then it's a different situation
there's no reason to to believe that you
understand what I'm saying
um but that fox should tone down the
rhetoric is a ridiculous comment from
someone at CNN not only because Fox gets
better ratings but because what he
really means is they should tone on the
Reddit they should stop fighting for
anything remotely close to conservative
values or for anything related to the
Republican party or anything else they
should just be like us they should just
be like us like would would CNN ever say
MSNBC should tone down the rhetoric
while they're demonizing the hell out of
parents who want to be involved in their
children's education or whatever they're
lying about desantisan on any given day
he would never say that because
left-wing rhetoric can be as hot as
possible but right-wing rhetoric we
should just be getting beaten and
bludgeoned all day long and just sit
there and take it one of the reasons
that the ladies of the view are so
excited that he's leaving and that that
Anderson Cooper is focused on his
rhetoric and the rhetoric of the network
is because he was making a difference he
was making a dent in their hegemonic
control of the media and and I and
mainstream cultures minds and guess what
once again ladies he's going to be
bigger than ever before but that did not
stop the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC you know this Nicole
Wallace she's one of the worst she's no
she's not Joy read level I'm not going
crazy today but she's quite horrible
here she is explaining a bit about why
it'll be good that Tucker Carlson will
be off Fox News
from election to nihilism and it's
violent manifestation January 6
Insurrection to Vladimir Putin's
propaganda about Ukraine which has
seeded opposition to the United States
response to the largest land war in
Europe since World War II
to conspiracies about covid-19 and the
vaccine and mask wearing to the
discussion around replacement Theory
which has actually been cited in the
manifestos of mass Shooters it is fair
to say it is not hyperbolic at all
to argue that Tucker Carlson is the
through line
through all of them
he's a champion of conspiracy theories
and until today he had one of the
largest audiences in cable news for
disseminating them
I mean it's really just incredible what
they're doing on MSC on MSNBC on a daily
basis you almost have to admire the evil
they lie about everything and then they
constantly play a shell game so Their
audience thinks that everyone else is
lying about everything just to quickly
go through a couple of the things that
she's accusing uh Tucker of election
denialism well first off you were
allowed to question this is still
America and you're allowed to question
what happens in elections you absolutely
are okay that's number one uh January
January 6th okay we've already this
thing was not an Insurrection there were
no plans we know cops were letting
people in I'm not even going to
entertain that one anymore Putin and
Ukraine it's the largest ground war in
Europe okay that doesn't mean you have
to be for it that doesn't mean the
United States should endlessly fund it
which is what he was complaining about
or that we should be in a war as Joe
manchin said we're in this war it's odd
because we don't have Congressional
approval on that thing so he was an
anti-war voice that used to be what the
left was all about anti-war remember it
was supposed to be mean Republicans and
conservatives who were Wars across the
world but somehow being anti-war means
you're a Putin puppet that he spread
conspiracies on covid-19 and facts and
mandates you guys did all the lying on
that that he was skeptical about
vaccines and mandates and everything
else and that she dared like after all
that we now know that she can stare into
that camera and just read what's put in
front of her because that's what she
does she's just reading off a prompter
and that she like like how soulless do
you have to be to do all that you may
not like Tucker Carlson you may not like
his political views you may not like him
personally or whatever but to lie you
lied once to your audience about all of
these things Trump Russia and collusion
and you hid the bunter the hunter laptop
and and covet you lied about all that
now one guy who was doing something a
little closer to the truth on all that
stuff gets canned you're ecstatic about
it and you'll lie to your audience again
about it despite the fact that so much
so much of it has been debunked it is
rather extraordinary people and again
you don't have to like what they're
doing uh but uh don't hate the hate the
game hate the pl wait don't hate the
player hate the game you know what I
mean like it's just these people are
just terrible
let's talk about fast growing trees and
then we'll get to more on all this guys
breed some life into your own backyard
with fastgrowingtrees.com this spring
from shade to fresh fruit to privacy and
natural beauty let fastgrowingtrees.com
help you plant your dream garden with
their expert advice and fast reliable
shipping
fastgrowingtrees.com's plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between no more waiting in
long lines and hauling heavy plants
around with fastgrowingtrees.com you
order online and your plants arrive at
your door in a couple days I love fast
going trees when uh when we got here we
planted a whole bunch we got lemon we
got lime we got uh well we got some
avocado a whole bunch of stuff you
should check them out I can't recommend
them enough and with fast growing trees
30 day alive and Thrive guarantee you
know everything will look great fresh
out of the box join Over 1.5 million
happy fast growing tree customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben right now
and get 15 off your entire order 50 15
off at
fastgrowingtrees.com
Reuben okay so now let's go back to Fox
right I could I could spend all day long
showing you the the fake and faux joy
that these people are showing well I
can't say it's fake they're showing I
would say short-term Joy uh but as you
know this will not work out for them in
the end but we could do all day on The
View and CNN and MSNBC clapping their
hands over this but let's focus on uh
where this thing all started and where
this takes Fox going forward because
this is going to hurt Fox everyone knows
it but I don't think everyone knows why
Fox will find Talent they are a massive
unbelievably massive influential giant
Corporation with millions and millions
of eyeballs and even if the landscape is
shaped changing rapidly and even if more
and more people are tuning into shows
like this and more and more people are
cutting the cord and everything else
they've got cash they've got resources
they have business plans they have
influenced all of those things right
they also have a digital side they have
Fox Nation so there's there's a whole
bunch of stuff that they have there
they're not going to just disappear but
in a way they are amplifying New Media
platforms as well because things like
Rumble are blowing up right now bongino
who left Fox is going all in on Rumble
he's been all in on Rumble uh before but
now he's going all in on it and you guys
know not only am I there and Crowders
there and Glenn greenwald's there and
Russell Brands they're like if you took
those names and you threw Tucker into
the mix you've got a bigger Network than
Fox MSNBC and CNN combined overnight so
the question is are are is there a way
that Network basically of independent
creators is actually better than an old
school
broadcast cable network right a new
platform and an alternative Vision
altogether so where will Tucker Carlson
end up well Dan bongino had a tweet that
I thought was rather straight to the
point he wrote Rumble then Assaf Lev
who's the CEO of locals my co-founder of
locals corporate media is dying
independent creators are the future of
media I agree then Chris pavlovsky who
is the CEO of Rumble I'm going to take
it a step further corporate media died
today independent creators are now the
lead interesting interesting interesting
let's go with another tweet from Chris
cable television is now completely
controlled speech Rumble is the only
Bastion for authentic speech all right
guys so what is the point here the point
is we can move mountains right now there
is an opportunity you get opportunity
every now and again and you usually
don't know when it's coming right but
all of us that were in this calcified
thing just think back to Trump in 2015
we all knew something was wrong we
didn't know what it was then Trump comes
in and blows up the machine I haven't
been that thrilled with Trump lately but
I give credit where credit is due and
that's what this situation with Tucker
is doing as well this connection between
corporate media and the New York Times
and big Tech and all of these things
it's it's had little holes punched
through with it through it with Elon at
Twitter and now with Tucker and with the
explosion of say what we're doing here
Crowder and all these things like these
things it's all happening but sometimes
you need that extra rocket fuel but the
truth is guys it's up to nobody but you
to decide what the market demands and
where the product is consumed that's
what we've been seeing over and over
again for the past Century the product
has been you the viewer and news has
mostly been free right so you just tune
into something they show you
advertisements on it and that was it but
you consume advertisements exchange for
free centralized corporate content right
eventually we all realize this when I
always tell you when you're watching
MSNBC and you know they know they're
lying well what are they doing they're
not acting as news people they're not
even they're not acting as journalists
or impartial uh even even the the
opinion people they know that they're
lying so they're they're in the business
actually of lying they're in the
business of servicing the machine and
when the machine does not need you
anymore say Brian stelter Don Lemon this
machine then gets rid of you but the
corporate press basically is selling you
to the advertisers so
I'm telling you this is what we are
going to do and I did not speak to
Tucker yesterday I am telling you just
the way the world is going and I think
Tucker is going to be part of it if you
can consume content at Rumble an
uncensored platform then you're
effectively kneecapping these outdated
corporate press Enterprises right if
you're saying I will watch the show on
Rumble instead of YouTube which is a
part of the problem you're departing the
corporate press and you're making them
bleed and if you don't believe me uh
just look what's happened in the last
couple weeks you have a chance to affect
things what happened uh with Bud Light
you know exactly what happened with Bud
Light they go all in on this trans
influencer
which I don't even know if she's had the
surgery and we're not going to do any
Googling about it today but this guy who
dresses up as a chick and pretends to be
the worst stereotype of a woman uh she
she he I hate this stupid stuff uh Dylan
Mulvaney then becomes the Bud Light
spokesperson and then because of you
guys
because the the average person that I
have had just about enough of this Bud
Light stock dropped about they lost
about seven billion dollars in market
share it sounds like they've gotten a
little bit of it back probably about 4
billion right now uh here's Savannah
Hernandez I've had her on the show I
believe one or two times uh who's she
often goes out to colleges and she tries
to Red Pill uh you know these leftist
college students in real time she was on
Tim Poole's podcast last night and I
think she made a really good point about
how to get wins and that dare I say it
but the right conservatives whatever you
want to call them are actually doing the
right thing but it's not just because of
Tucker and Tim it's because of you
20 of people no longer buy beer than Bud
light's market cap will drop by 20 and
stay there and once it stabilizes 20
lower it they will say the the boy cuts
over the decline in sales has ended
despite the fact what really happened is
no one is coming back to buy their beer
yeah right right and you know what I
will say too I actually am Pride uh
proud of the right wing for you know
staking it Sennheiser Bush and actually
sending this message because typically
in the past I feel like we get angry
about things but we're internet Warriors
and that's about it so I mean seeing the
pushback on this uh has been great and
uh I think it has sent a message to a
lot of other corporations as well and
they're gonna start being more careful
about uh what they're advertising
okay so I think you see the connection
I'm trying to make here we don't know
whether Tucker voluntarily left or they
pushed him out the door where there was
a little bit of both but there's a
game-changing moment happening in
television media and and let's say
online media then if you connect that
with the fact that a game-changing
moment happened just last week with this
massive boycott people are not going to
go back to Bud Light like you can feel
it Savannah's right this is different
than usually people just tweet about
things and I'm so angry about something
and I threw my Keurig coffee machine in
the garbage
something is different right now and
these these winds these little moments
they start sticking together and then
then something can start taking form so
this is the result of you the non-woe
consumer the decision maker the person
with a little autonomy over your life
and your dollars uh saying to the market
hey I would not like to be abused
relentlessly anymore and then you know
what happens after that then the market
does some different things so we've got
some info here from the daily wire
Bud Light marketing VP takes leave of
absence amid Dylan Mulvaney controversy
that was the woman who uh set up the
whole thing in the first place who we
played the video of her last week you
remember who was basically saying we
don't like the Frat Boys that are
drinking Bud Light so we want it to be
more diverse and here we go well she's
now okay she's out a little more from
the daily wire Anheuser-Busch places
another top marketing executive on leave
after Bud Light transgender
controversy so now do you see it guys
that didn't happen solely because Tucker
talked about it or because bongino
talked about it or any of us talked
about it even though we did it was
because people heard the message they
were fed up enough and then they walked
into the supermarket and they said today
I will have Connor beer please
Coors Light instead of Bud Light you can
probably do better than Coors Light
people but people made choices so what
else has happened you have to look no
further than corporate press Outlets
when ratings are falling in crazy ways
because of their increasing partisanship
the outlet eventually has to make
radical changes this is exactly what's
happening at CNN right they're firing
people left and right lemon stelter a
whole bunch of other people they're
saying we're going to not be as partisan
as we were well we've got a little info
on how it's all working out for CNN at
the moment this is from Forbes February
marked CNN's lowest rated month in a
decade with the Network's Prime Time
lineup dropping 42 percent among viewers
25 to 54 the key demographic group
valued by advertisers compared to the
same month one year ago for full day
ratings Fox News easily won the month
with an average of total audience of
1.437 million viewers down 14 from a
year ago followed by MSNBC 711 000
viewers down just one percent and CNN
474 000 viewers down 24
CNN's struggling Morning Show CNN this
morning averaged 360
000 total viewers and just 73 000
viewers in the key demo in February the
show's lowest rated month since it
launched last fall the show debuted in
November ratings to lower than the show
it had replaced new day and has failed
to make much traction since then with
critics noting that instead of chemistry
the hosts Caitlyn Collins Don Lemon and
Poppy Harlow often talk over each other
the show also suffered from lemon making
sexist comments in a discussion about
Republican presidential candidate Nikki
Haley's age saying Haley isn't in her
prime because at 51 women are considered
to be in their Prime in their 20s and
30s and maybe 40s lemon apologized off
air but his remarks LED CNN chief
executive Chris Licht to tell staff I
sat down with Don and had a friend make
a meaningful conversation lick said an
internal memo he has agreed to
participate in formal training as well
as continuing to listen and learn we
take this very seriously Flash Forward
two months and Don Lemon tweeted this
I was informed this morning by my agent
that I have been terminated by CNN I am
stunned after 17 years at CNN I would
have thought that someone in management
would have had the decency to tell me
directly at no time was I given any
indication that I would not be able to
continue to do the work I have loved at
the network it is clear that there are
some larger issues at play with that
said I want to thank my colleagues and
the many teams I've worked with for an
incredible run they are the most
talented journalists in the business and
I wish them all the best and within
moments of that statement CNN had to
refute him because that was fake news
here's from CNN comes Don lemon's
statement about this morning's events is
inaccurate he was offered an opportunity
to meet with management but instead
released a statement on Twitter so again
guys I want to connect what's going on
here we are seeing alternative platforms
blow up we are seeing that you the
consumer has a little bit of clout by
making choices yourself because if you
start doing it then other people start
doing it and then what happens Bud Light
loses money and new beers will be out
there or people will drink tequila
perhaps or whatever it else might be you
stop watching CNN and stop swallowing
their propaganda and then the
propagandists like Brian stelter and Don
Lemon actually get fired and it all
starts burning down this is good this is
all good uh so now you might wonder well
Dave
I'm just a casual news consumer I never
thought that Don Lemon was really that
terrible I thought he was pretty good
why why would you take him off air he's
a decent fella you know is this some
sort of racist homophobic situation
do you have some videotape perhaps that
might show us that Don Lemon was
terrible I do here you go
the word on the street is that you guys
aren't allowed to be liberal anymore is
that is that the case I don't think you
ever were liberal what yes I'm not a
political person I'm a person who lives
in reality I'm a journalist we have to
stop demonizing people and realize the
biggest Terror threat in this country is
white men and we have to start doing
something about them there is no white
guy band so what do we do about that a
woman is considered being a prime in her
20s and 30s and maybe 40s that's not
according to me if you Google when is a
woman in a prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s it says it right in the name antifa
anti-fascism which is what they were
there
um fighting listen there's you know no
organization is perfect there was some
violence right now are democracies
endangering it's because of one party
and that's the Republican Party the only
party now that is operating in reality
is the Democratic party open your eyes
America open your eyes we are teetering
on a dictatorship they are America's
first couple the closest thing that we
have to royalty President Barack Obama
and the First Lady Michelle Obama just
objectively speaking I was like oh my
gosh
Nancy Pelosi is a boss and let's not
forget if anyone is judging this I'm not
judging this our country was started
because this is how the Boston Tea Party
rioting
this is how this country was started
all right look
with any luck that's the last non-lemon
clip we ever have to show you like he's
got a lot of money just like go
disappear retired on you know he'll show
up on some third-rate Network okay fine
but hopefully we'll just be able to
ignore him but just remember he always
purported to be a journalist I just want
to reiterate one more time I do not
pretend to be a journalist I am not a
journalist I am not out in the field
fact finding and all of those things I
am attaining information throughout the
day the way any of us attain information
and then I apply My Philosophy and my
thoughts to it and I communicate that
stuff to you I don't hide what my biases
are right he was always hiding what his
biases are but doing it quite poorly so
he did not deserve to be on a network
that is supposed to be unbiased or at
least say it say what your biases say I
am an opinion show but they got too lost
in that that took out stelter too and
and thankfully again less and less
people are paying attention to this
nonsense so the question is how can we
enact this market-demanding model across
the board so that we can really change
things because it is happening in front
of our eyes well I got a couple ideas
number one we can keep doing it to woke
companies like Bud Light stop paying for
your demise it's why I canceled Disney
plus so when my kids are old enough and
they want to watch the original Lion
King we'll figure it out I'm gonna have
to go to my parents house in the
basement in the back room by the furnace
open up the box find the VHS tape I'm
gonna have to find a VCR I'm gonna have
to find a cable that'll connect it to my
TV because the cables don't match
anymore and I'm gonna go the kid can
watch Lion King but I will not pay
Disney to do it I will not drink Bud
Light again I'm a tequila guy but maybe
you should stop drinking Bud Light
number two what can you do you can keep
doing it to woke mainstream media
corporations like CNN tune out and I
know I'm if I'm talking to you you're
not watching these things a lot but you
have family members who do you have
husbands and wives who you come home and
they're watching CNN and you go Jesus
Christ again with that but we've got to
just convince more and more people to
tune out of the nonsense because it is
brainwashing people into hysteria number
three this is the one I really like how
about we offer better alternatives to
the truth tellers like Tucker and even
if you don't like Tucker and even if
someone's not offering truth let's say
how about we just create more pipes more
avenues for people to do what they want
and if it is good and if it is valuable
people will tune in somehow I don't know
how but somehow 10 years ago I started
getting on this idea that there was a
way to do it myself and that was the
future of all these things and not to
Pat myself on the back but that's why
Tucker Carlson who had the number one
rated show in the world at that time
news show walked into my house even
though he's making 50 times the the
money I'm making and everything else and
was jealous of what I had in the
inscription of the book that was for his
book Ship of Fools in the inscription he
wrote David doing it for all the suckers
who are still in offices like how cool
is that and now I then created locals we
merged with Rumble and we have the pipes
to Now set him free how freaking awesome
is that pretty cool we just did it for
Crowder too not bad not bad number four
how about
this is the Segway to the next part of
the show
how about we not only do it when it
comes to what you're buying and what
you're watching but we start doing it
politically as well now let's talk about
presidential politics because as
Bloomberg reported
yesterday
Joe Biden officially launches bid for
re-election in 2024. to be clear before
we show you the video Joe Biden will be
82 years old in 2024. Joe Biden has some
form of Dementia or some other cognitive
problem
Dr Jill Biden his wife does not care
despite the fact that she's a very
important and very influential doctor
and Joe Biden is basically the perfect
vessel for all these ridiculous woke
ideas that's all he is he is just a sort
of brainless
swamp creature zombie who puts out
whatever reads whatever they want him to
read
often poorly mumbles and stumbles he has
no real support he's sort of just
perfect for what they are ushering in
but what's interesting about this is
everyone kind of knows it there are very
few hardcore Joe Biden supporters the
voter Market if you want to talk about
the market and market share related to
beer related to what people watch well
how about related to voting too the
market does not want him to run so let's
not give it to him here's Chuck Todd on
NBC even admitting that most people do
not want Joe Biden's run more than half
of the people who voted for him in 2020.
53 of 2020 Biden voters say he shouldn't
run 64 of Democrats who voted for
Sanders were worn in the 2020 primaries
think he shouldn't run and 76 percent of
Voters under 35 think he shouldn't run
and what's the top concern for that we
asked voters we didn't prompt them we
said why don't you think he should run
well these were the responses it almost
is all about his age and his ability to
do the job again these are among
Democratic primary voters I want to just
hit something again about the age
because this is just going to keep
coming up and keep coming up I do
generally believe that at 82 years old
you should not be president of the
United States like it's just time to go
be a grandfather not that those
grandchildren want to be near him with
the sniffing of the hair and all that
stuff but like it's just too old but I
would also say in the world that we live
in now where the last 20 years have have
been an absolute revolution of
technology and information and
communication the idea that Joe Biden is
going to lead us to the other side of
that is so stagnated and so crazy and so
it's such a broken nonsensical idea that
again I think it's perfect for the
Democrats because they don't want the
new world to be ushered in they want a
world to be ushered in that will be of
more centralized control and of more
power over your decisions and much more
but it is not specifically about his age
and I just do want to say that one more
time my problem with Joe Biden it really
isn't despite I think you can make a
good argument about that right he grew
up in a completely different world we
need leaders who are somewhere in their
40s and 50s even into their 60s right
now I would take late 30s too somewhere
in that 30 40-year age range where
you're still in your Prime of all these
things you've gotten the youth part out
of the way you're not in your your the
Dawn you're not in the the sunset of the
situation right uh but you were in the
you were able physically and mentally to
do all of it and that's just not Joe
Biden even if he had the right ideas
it's just not Joe Biden on top of the
fact that he obviously have cognitive
problems he's shaking hands with nobody
he's wandering around they don't know
where the hell he is he's taking orders
from the Easter Bunny we got problems
people uh so you know what you could do
you know what you could do if you're
watching this I think you've probably
made up your mind already but you could
not vote for Biden you could not support
Biden you could try to convince your
friends who are supporting the Democrats
or Joe Biden that there are better
people out there and you might want to
say to some of them the ones who were
like you know I I I'm actually not
against Donald Trump's policies I just
don't like his Mean Tweets and his
attitude if he if there was only
somebody that had similar policies that
seemed like a nice guy uh who didn't
tweet a lot and didn't get into all the
personal attacks and be over the top
nonsense if only such a guy existed
and then you could say to them oh you
know a guy does exist Hannity added him
on his show last night from Japan
and I have one follow-up
so I've said from the election of 2022
and people started asking me uh we got a
legislative session that we're working
on we've got a few more weeks to go with
that we're going to be putting up a lot
of wins on the board and so I'm not
going to be making any announcements
before that's concluded okay are you
leaning one way or another
stay tuned
all right that got a good that got a
good chuckle okay so look we shall see
if DeSantis gets in as you know I don't
have to smack you over the head with it
I I think he's the right guy to get us
through this it is a combination of all
of the things I'm talking about he's
fought the corporations Disney and won
he's fought the political establishment
and turned Florida solidly red he's not
giving in to the media nonsense and he's
boycotting talks with NBC because they
keep lying about him he's not feeding
the Beast endlessly he's personally
barely on social media so he's focused
on the mission he's younger three kids
Good Wife like it all kind of fits but
okay
so what's the point of all this well
guys if we the market we the consumer if
we truly support who we want to support
with our honest actions as opposed to
our closeted beliefs right if we put
this stuff into action then we can
actually make the world a better place
there will be platforms like Rumble that
are going to allow us to do that because
we're not going to fear censorship what
have we all been fearing for these these
years right it's that we'd either be
Shadow banned or kicked off uh this
platform or that platform or that you'd
be fired from your job if you didn't get
uh injected with something or all of
those things so we were all fearing this
stuff but we're getting to the other
side of it we really are and it's by the
way a lot of pain points on the way to
the other side but I believe it guys the
truth will set you free
I don't think I'm the first person to
say that probably the second but here's
another guy saying something like that
his name Tucker Carlson
and once you say one true thing and
stick with it all kinds of other true
things occur to you
the truth is contagious lying is but the
truth is as well
and the second you decide to tell the
truth about something you are filled
with this I don't get Supernatural on
you
but you are filled with this power from
somewhere else try it tell the truth
about something you feel it every day
the more you tell the truth the stronger
you become
that's completely real
it's measurable in the way that you feel
and of course the opposite is also true
the more you lie the weaker and more
terrified you become we all know that
feeling you lie about something and all
of a sudden you're a prisoner of that
lie you are diminished by it you are
weak and Afraid
drug and alcohol use is the same way it
makes you weak and Afraid
but you look around and you see these
people and some of them really have paid
a heavy price for telling the truth
and they are cast out of their groups
whatever those groups are but they do it
anyway
and I look on at those people with the
deepest possible admiration I am paid to
do that
I face no penalty
someone comes to me you're so brave
really I'm a talk show host
negative any opinion I want that's my
job that's why they pay me it's not
brave to tell the truth on a cable news
show and if you're not doing that you're
really an idiot you're really craving
you're lying on television why would you
do that
you're literally making a living to say
what you think and you can't even do
that
please
I mean is that a nice summation of a
bunch of the stuff that I talk about on
this show every day tell the truth see
what happens he's right it is measurable
Jordan Peterson talks about this all the
time it's measurable at a physiological
level because when you put truth out to
the world the world starts ordering
itself and the idea that there are these
people and you we don't have to go
through who they are we showed you some
clips of them that they get up there and
they lie constantly and then they
applaud the supposed demise of the truth
tellers and they get paid handsomely for
it I think their day is coming to a
close I really do we are in an
interesting battle and an interesting
battle is not one in a day right Elon
Tucker Rumble
all of these things are part of a new
world being born and I am very excited
that you are on the journey with me on
that new world speaking of new worlds
I'm I'm going pretty old world for the
next week and a half or so I leave
tomorrow I am going to the Holy Land the
promised land the other Promised Land
I'm in the real Promised Land right here
in Florida but I'm going to the other
Promised Land uh Israel uh and I'm going
to have a couple speaking events I have
a live one May 4th uh in Tel Aviv which
we will I sent out a tweet about we'll
be promoting all over the place I'll be
speaking at a couple forums there and
we're bouncing all over the country and
doing some interviews and actually it
sounds like on Thursday uh Governor
DeSantis is going to be there so I'm
going to try to get to an event that
he's doing sounds like some
Congressional Republicans will also be
there so we're going to do some stuff
related to America but really focus on
the historical sites and a bunch more
we're going to put up a ton of content
for you guys while we're there I've
pre-taped a couple interviews we
pre-taped tomorrow's show and Thursday's
show for you already so we got a q a and
a panel show coming for you so we're not
going to leave you hanging and I'm very
excited to so we're going to do about 10
days in Israel then about four days in
Budapest I'll be doing a show with
Jordan Peterson in Buddha Budapest I'll
be speaking at the Danube Institute a
couple other things happening there so
just stay tuned and if you're in Israel
or hungry I'd love to meet you and we're
gonna you know be out there and we'll do
some meetups and meet up at bars and
beaches and whatever might be happening
finally people if you haven't subscribed
at rumble.com Ruben report I mean did I
give you a hard enough sell today it's
the future I think there might be
something cooking with Tucker hey I
can't say anything else what do I know
what do I don't I don't know nothing
okay uh and if you want to join us for a
post game show uh in about a minute join
us at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with Constantine kissing is up
on YouTube and Rumble right now full
things up over at locals absolutely
ad-free and oh I guess I lied and I have
to correct myself I said earlier in the
show we may not have to show you any
more Don Lemon I forgot out with the
cold clothes was the cold close is just
more lemon
this is I have to retract what I just
said to you so I apologize in advance
here's a little more lemon and we'll see
everybody on the other side
it's one of the co-hosts of CNN this
morning
Donald lemon black people if you really
want to fix the problem here's just five
things that you should think about doing
is it fair to say this because I'm not a
mommy but is it mommy praying have you
ever considered that you may just be
perpetuating The Stereotype the master
intended acting like she did not say
that she did not say that she did say it
she did not she said it out can we get
back to soccer the men's team makes more
money because because people are more
interested
what are you drinking there Don Latino
soda walking around with your ass and
your underwear showing is not okay
Smollett testify that anchor Shannon
anchor Don Lemon texted him at the time
of the attack sharing information that
the Chicago Police Department did not
believe smollett's account of what
happened just because you can have a
baby it doesn't mean you should I'm not
sexist by the way I don't mean to be
crude okay yeah there are ways not to
perform oral sex if you
I used to date her I gotta say
everywhere I go and you know what I'm
going to ask you people say hey that
guy's on your show is he really running
for president but just because you have
the right
does it mean that you should no no just
come here no no I just want to ask you
something come here tell me come here I
want you to talk what's your name every
Monday
[Music]